you will emerge today's episode Atomics
for peace
when you emerge from the comfort and
safety of your vault the world you know
will have changed take your friendly old
neighbor Johnny rather than coming over
to borrow a cup of sugar he may now be
coming over for murder worse still he
may not be alone in this instance your
current defensive implement will not be
enough to do the job the time has come
to seek out greater means of protection
nuclear armaments that's right
courtesy of your Uncle Sam these wonders
of the atomic age can be found right in
your own backyard but how does a fellow
like you acquire nuclear launch codes
you may ask begin by inquiring with the
locals gently coax them into cooperation
use a little elbow grease if you have to
in the likely event you don't acquire a
full code on your own do not give up
think back to the old saying the enemy
of your enemy is your friend search for
others who might be harboring a grudge
you'll have that nuclear launch code in
no time with the power of the atom at
your fingertips be responsible and
consider your target carefully will your
bomb land on a rival camp of degenerates
a random stranger the local wildlife the
choice is yours
[Music]
whatever your target may be take
advantage of the resulting fall out
together rare and valuable resources yet
these rewards don't come without risk
monitor your environment for anything
out of the ordinary now you know the
benefits of using Atomics for peace you
are completely prepared to responsibly
use nuclear weapons as a hand-picked
resident of vault
76 it is your duty to carefully review
your vault-tec provided films yearly to
fully prepare for the day when you will
emerge play the beta first on Xbox one
[Music]